vamos con nuestra sección de economía y
la actualización con Daniela Daniela
vamos a empezar esta vez hablando del
canciller ruso y las burlas públicas que
recibió mientras hablaba de economía sí
Ángela Pues el ministro de relaciones
exteriores de ese país labrov estaba
hablando de economía durante la Cumbre
de cancilleres del g20 en Nueva Delhi y
fue interrumpido por miembros de la
audiencia cuando pronunció la siguiente
frase
[Música]
influence influence influencers
el canciller ruso se vio bastante serio
y él continuó con su discurso a pesar de
este boicot que querían hacerle y hablo
también de Occidente
la forma contundente de describir lo que
cambió es no vamos a depender más de
ningún socio en occidente no vamos a
permitir que atenten contra los
gasoductos de nuevo
la política energética de Rusia se
orientará hacia socios confiables socios
creíbles India y China ciertamente se
encuentran entre ellos
el habla de este Sabotaje que está
investigando precisamente Naciones
Unidas ocurrió en septiembre pasado en
los gasoductos Norte y dos que van de
Rusia a Europa occidental recordemos que
el primero llevo gas ruso a Alemania
hasta que Moscú cortó el suministro a
finales de agosto de 2022 y el segundo
nunca entró en servicio ya que Alemania
suspendió su proceso de certificación
antes de la invasión bueno de todas
maneras usted no debe ser nada fácil es
sergei la profe y defender a Rusia ante
el mundo no Daniela vamos a cambiar de
tema en Nigeria hay es de efectivo por
la prohibición de utilizar billetes
antiguos esto ya se venía se veía venir
desde antes de las elecciones No ya
había empezado la medida convierte en un
tema político Ya vamos a ver por qué el
Banco Central de ese país el más poblado
de África había puesto como fecha límite
el 10 de febrero de este año para que
los billetes antiguos dejaran de ser de
curso legal y reemplazarlos por unos
nuevos en un país donde la mayoría de la
gente depende del dinero en efectivo
para todo desde pagar un billete de bus
hasta comprar alimentos en los mercados
la escasez de estos billetes ha irritado
a los ciudadanos algunos de ellos han
atacado bancos inclusive han llegado a
quemar cajeros automáticos pues la Corte
Suprema le ordenó hoy al Banco Central
extender ese plazo por lo menos hasta el
31 de diciembre
el tema trascendió como usted decía a lo
político no Claro porque el gobierno del
presidente muhammadú bujary ha defendido
el plan del Banco Central de retirar los
antiguos billetes que son los de 1500 y
los nairas diciendo que eso frenaría el
lavado de dinero también en los
secuestros para pedir rescates y que
ofrecería una mayor transparencia en las
transacciones financieras sin embargo
esta medida ha causado divisiones dentro
del gobernante congreso de los
progresistas porque varios de sus
miembros dicen que ese plan puso a los
votantes en contra del partido Aunque
finalmente su candidato fue Quien ganó
las elecciones pues Daniela puede que
ayude pero pasa más por temas
estructurales el combate de la violencia
vamos ahora hasta México porque este
país Busca liderar un acuerdo regional
que ayude a frenar la inflación el
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
Ángela dijo que ya ha estado en
conversaciones con sus homólogos de
América Latina esto para analizar qué
pueden hacer conjuntamente para reducir
los precios de la canasta familiar y no
individualmente por ejemplo eliminando
ciertos aranceles o también mirando como
pueden intercambiar exportaciones e
importaciones a propósito de esto pues
vamos a darle un repaso a cómo estuvo la
de América Latina en 2022 tenemos el
país más inflacionario de la región
Argentina con un 94,8% su tasa más alta
desde 1991 Colombia con un 13,1%
registró su mayor inflación en 23 años
chile 12,8% es la más alta desde 1991 y
México está un poco por debajo
7,82% Aunque sigue siendo la más alta en
dos décadas Brasil
5,79% no es la situación tan grave como
en otros países vecinos y Bolivia es la
tasa más baja de la región de la región
3,12% registro en el 2022 Bueno no es la
primera vez que López Obrador quiere
llevar a cabo iniciativas como esta
vamos a ver cómo le va y vamos a pasar a
otra noticia los precios mundiales de
los alimentos cayeron por un décimo mes
consecutivo Así es el índice de la
Organización de Naciones Unidas para la
alimentación y la agricultura que
rastrea los productos más
comercializados a nivel mundial tocó
récord histórico en marzo del año pasado
justo después de la invasión rusa a
Ucrania desde entonces se ha venido
desacelerando en febrero tuvo su lectura
más baja desde septiembre de 2021 y hoy
los precios están diecinueve por ciento
por debajo de ese máximo histórico según
la FAO lo que más cayó fueron aceites
vegetales y productos lácteos y esto
compensó un fuerte aumento en los
precios del azúcar es un buen momento
Daniela para que hablemos de los
indicadores Ángela los mercados
bursátiles mundiales Comenzando por Asia
están positivos este viernes después de
que un funcionario de la reserva Federal
expresara la esperanza de que el Banco
Central no sería tan agresivo con los
aumentos de tasa de interés Wall Street
había subido el jueves también por
primera vez en tres días y Europa se
contagió hoy de ese optimismo después de
que el presidente del banco de la
reserva Federal de Atlanta Rafael
bosstic expresará su apoyo a Elevar la
tasa de interés de la Fed menos de lo
que pronostican muchos inversionistas y
esto lo que hace es animarlos a invertir
más en acciones Daniel el agradecimiento
para